im Internet gibt es zahlreiche Artikel
zur besten Business Class der Welt mal
ist es Singapore Airlines mal Emirates
mal Qatar Airways manchmal auch wiir
okay kleiner Spaß ich hasse die ich habe
mir als Aufgabe gesetzt alle Top 10
business classes selber zu testen und
mein eigenes Ranking zu erstellen wir
starten heute mit Qatar Airways ich
hatte mein Vergnügen mit Qatar Airways
auf dem Rückflug von Bangkok nach
Frankfurt und musste in Doha umsteigen
glücklicherweise in eine Boeing 777 mit
der Qatar Airways Q Suite dem
Aushängeschild von Business Class Flügen
mit dieser Airline hier hatte ich super
viel Platz und konnte meinen sitzblattz
sogar komplett verschließen eigentlich
also wie First Class bei anderen
Airlines es gab mehrere Gänge als
Vorspeise dann Hauptgang den ich nicht
mehr geschafft habe weil ich auf dem
Flug von Bangkok nach Doha auch schon so
viel gegessen habe und vorher in der
Lounge in Bangkok die wirklich
phänomenal war auch schon aber das Essen
war wirklich überall super vielfältig
und krank lecker so sah dann auch das
Frühstück am nächsten Morgen aus mit
tollem Sonnenaufgang und Anflug auf
Frankfurt Flughafen der Flug war ein
absolutes Erlebnis und ich bin entspannt
angekommen ob das